it's difficult to research something if
you don't know the name of it I got an
email a few days ago asking if I could
figure out anything about this anomaly I
try to discourage messages like that I'm
not Google I'm not a reference librarian
but this thing completely nerd snipe me
because other than one reference on
Wikipedia to this exact light that's
used for shipping on Southampton water I
couldn't find anything about it which is
weird because this is a really clever
idea
this light is based on wiry patterns
which are the extra lines and patches
that seem to appear when you have two
similar but slightly different patterns
overlaid on each other you can see them
in a few places but most of the time
they are confusing and distracting and
designers want to avoid them but here
the patterns are set up so that if
you're looking straight at that light
dead-on you see parallel lines but if
you're to either side the arrows formed
by the moiré patterns tell you which way
to go to be straight onto it you can
have five different boats in five
different locations out there all
looking at the same sign and they will
all see arrows pointing the right way
for them without any computers or fancy
tracking this seems like such a good
idea that I couldn't believe it wasn't
well known so I went searching soirée
shipping like Mauri boat light and after
half hour or so I'd found a couple of
others around the UK placed at the
entrances to locks and marinas or at the
end of dredged channels so that people
steering a boat know exactly which way
to go to avoid the sides one guide for
Mariners called it an inner gem light
but that just led me to a medical
company nothing else and that was it it
looked like a bit of weird maritime
history that had but a brief fad and
then died out leaving no trace a
beautiful idea that the world had
ignored I considered starting a new
series of videos called
I don't know just to see if anyone knew
more about it because it's genius and
yeah I wanted to understand it so much
that my brain wasn't quite done I kept
coming back I kept searching and
eventually I started looking through
patent databases and after a few minutes
I found it it was patented by Lars Berg
fist and Ivan forced him from Sweden in
the late 1970s they'd invented several
things to do with Maurey patterns
between them and though there are a few
more patents after the first refining
the idea
making work in two dimensions with
circles the trail ended there I try to
track Lars / Ivan down and couldn't find
any trace the only thing I had was an
address from about 40 years ago in
Sweden and then one little clue spotted
just out the corner of my eye unlocked
everything yes this was patented by Berg
fist enforcement but the patent was then
assigned to a company called inner God
not in a gen that was a typo a
corruption of the name overtime in oh
god this is known as an inner gun
leading mark or just an inner gun light
and once you know that once you name it
you can search for it you can find the
US military analysis from 1986 testing
that it works are the variations that
were made for getting an aircraft into
the right place parking in a stand the
Swedish company called FMT that now
makes them or did until recently because
they just removed it from their website
once you know that this is an inner gun
light all the rest of the research
becomes easy
all except one thing this inner gun
light isn't being used to guide people
in the light follows the path of an
underwater cable where you shouldn't
drop anchor so the signal here is
something wrong you don't want to follow
these arrows you're required to stay
away from them unless you're passing
straight through it's a really weird use
for a very expensive light so why is it
here I don't know but if anyone out
there does know for sure with evidence
do get in touch